alors après un mois de confinement les
français continuent de prendre leur mal
en patience entre relâchement et
poursuite des efforts certains
commencent à trouver le temps long
réactions dans les rues de mon père
d'après un mois de confinement
on a vite fait le tour de toute façon on
s'embête un peu mais bon on fait on fait
comme on peut quoi on essaie de passer
le temps à la maison
après il ya tout ce qui est en rôti
console heureusement
et sinon c'est un peu c'est un peu long
surtout quand il fait beau comme ça quoi
ça semble long mais en même temps on
sent plus en sécurité
c'est si c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire après si ça se prolonge ce
sera plus dur mais bon là on prend les
choses pour les choses avec philosophie
et avec de la patience je crois c'est
vraiment dur dur dur dur le compliment
est bon c'est vrai on est là on n'a pas
le choix quoi d'un côté c'est bien
d'écouter c'est pas bien mais voilà
mais par contre on est contre le 11 mai
moi personnellement je mettrais pas mon
fils à l'école ça que c'est un peu long
mais bon ya pas trop le choix donc fait
comme tout le monde on patiente
moi je continue à travailler donc ça
change pas grand chose mais après c'est
ma femme qui s'occupe des enfants à la
maison et c'est tout c'est l'eau c'est
le romero n'est obligé de faire avec
donc on me fait rire aux ringards
il ya le chien va pouvoir un peu hâlé
balade et puis voilà on a un petit
terrain privatise derrière l'immeuble
pour ma part je me sens perdue
je me sens un peu on a on a du mal à
avoir des objectifs à moyen terme même à
court terme parce qu'on sait pas trop à
quelle sauce on va être mangés demain
même si le président nous a fait des
annonces mais bon chacun a son avis sur
le sujet et ça nous éclaire pas
forcément le chemin